vision residents  after end game we find vision and wonder  in the 1950s in this sort of sitcom town  i think it's going to be a really fun  surprise for the audience  the costuming on this is magnificent the  colors that we have to do for black and  white how it's different it's just wild  that you're thinking of those things  mayas the designer is such a genius and  such an artist this has been an  incredible project for me because it  allows me to design costumes of many  fashion eras  juan division is truly recreating the  experience in those shows decade by  decade we're all just getting to really  invest  with wardrobe hair makeup design  everything  it's been such an imaginative and fun  project to work on this is gonna be a  gas